President Trump is trying to rally
Senate Republicans to push through more
of his nominees and to push harder
toward holding on to their majority in
November but there continues to be a
separate push among senators for some
kind of response to an insult against
one of their own chief White House
correspondent John Roberts is here with
that story tonight from the North Lawn
TV John Brett could it be to you just a
few minutes ago the president returned
here to the White House he'd been up at
the Walter Reed National Military
Medical Center visiting with the first
lady as she continues to recover from a
kidney procedure earlier today he was on
Capitol Hill spending time with Senate
Republicans pushing his legislative
priorities President Trump came to
Capitol Hill today with a lot on his
mind
first and foremost the slow pace of
confirmations for his nominees the
president casting that Democrat says
obstructionists who are standing in the
way of getting his staff in place but
exiting the meeting senators preferred
to focus on what's been done rather than
work out standing we were all in a
celebratory mood as a result of having
approved the 21st Circuit Judge just a
few moments ago President Trump had a
number of other items on his agenda to
talk about including appropriations
making sure he doesn't get more omnibus
spending bills funding for a border wall
and the latest developments with Iran
and North Korea the president will also
again push Congress for immigration
reform this morning he used the backdrop
of the annual National Peace Officers
Memorial Service to drive home the
urgency that is why we are calling on
Congress to secure our borders support
our border agents stop sanctuary cities
and shut down policies that release
violent criminals back into our
communities we don't want it any longer
we've had it enough is enough one topic
that didn't come up even though Iowa
Senator Joni Ernst wanted to raise it
was the cutting remark White House
staffer Kelly Sadler made about Senator
John McCain in a meeting last week a
growing number of senators now saying
Sadler the
Whitehouse or both should apologize the
person who said that should apologize
and should apologize publicly if I had
said that I would apologize they're just
things you don't say and shouldn't say
White House staffers tell Fox to use
Sadler could have easily put the issue
to rest by making a public apology to
McCain last week and according to
sources that was initially the plan but
the plan changed
Sadler dug in her heels in six days
later the issue was gathering steam in
an effort to change the subject
president Trump made the insult all
about the fact that was leaked tweeting
the so-called leaks coming out of the
White House or a massive
over-exaggeration put up by the fake
news media in order to make us look as
bad as possible with that being said
leakers are traitors and cowards and we
will find out who they are sources say
there were about 30 people in the
meeting where the remark was made
officials believe it was leaked simply
to damage the President and that there
will likely be repercussions
I had several discussions with the
President on this very topic today do
you expect personnel changes as a result
I do actually yes they do
Kellyanne Conway said that she thinks
that a lot of staffers use leaks to try
to quote Shiv each other and while leaks
are a tried-and-true tradition here in
Washington DC this White House does seem
to have a set a new standard at least
for the volume of agenda-driven leaks
Brett John Roberts thought of the North
Lawn John thanks